the Norwegian Nobel Committee has
decided to award the Nobel Peace Prize
for 2010 to Li Jie habu for his long and
non violent struggle for fundamental
human rights in China the Norwegian
Nobel Committee has long believed that
there is a close connection between
human rights and peace
such rights are a prerequisite for the
fraternity between nations of which
Alfred Nobel wrote in his will over the
past decades China has achieved economic
advances to which history can hardly
show any equal the country now has the
world's second largest economy hundreds
or millions of people have been lifted
after poverty scope for political
participation has also broadened China's
new status must intend increased
responsibility China is in breach of
several international agreements to
which it is a signatory as well as of
its own provisions concerning political
rights article 35 or China's
Constitution lays down that I am a quote
citizens of the People's Republic of
China enjoy freedom of speech of the
press or assembly of association or
procession and of demonstration and both
in practice these freedoms have proved
to be distinctly curtailed for China
citizens for over two decades Li you
Tiago has been a strong spokesman for
the application of fundamental human
rights also in China he took part in the
Tiananmen protests in 1989 he was a
leading author behind chart
or eight the manifesto of church rights
in China which was published on the 60th
anniversary of the United Nations
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
the following year Lee was sentenced to
11 years in prison and two years
deprivation of political rights for
inciting subversion of state power Li
Yue has constantly maintained that the
sentence was what violates both China's
own Constitution and fundamental human
rights the campaign to establish
universal human rights also in China is
being waged by many Chinese balls in
China itself and abroad through the
severe punishment meted out to him
li Yu has become the foremost symbol of
this wide-ranging struggle for human
rights in China thank you very much